[Musica]
ciao a tutti ragazzi su sixty seconds
che su specchi in questo senso perché è
una volta all'anno io un episodio una
volta all'anno
una volta all'anno allo ragazzi di
impostazioni di difficoltà e sempre
nella media perché questo gioco è già
difficile modalità easy quindi
figuriamoci quando la difficoltà è già
molto
allora mi sembra non so la migliore
delle ipotesi questa dove non c'è il
padre so senza di lui
andiamo avanti vediamo quanto del giorno
1 perché sa dove ti ho messo il 4 è
quello fa niente allora possiamo andare
mary jane che tanto è quella che non
trova in a sega quindi no ma andiamo
alla mamma
vai dolores sono altre questioni a cui
pensare nessuno riesce a dormire bisogna
subito risolvere altrimenti rischiavo di
addormentarci ma cosa ci vuoi fare gol
come vuoi dormire col kit medico
spiegami con quale criterio chi dovrei
fare cosa vuoi darci la testa che lo
sfascio tutto
ma scusa comunque finché euro richiesti
dov'è andata per i geni tutor letto da
dolores unico fondo sembra la madre con
la figlia giorno acqua e cibo a tutti ok
vediamo cosa c'è qua non è che di solito
l'odore del nostro rifugio si è così
gradevole ma abbiamo iniziato ad
apprezzarlo al primo senza di bruciato
l'odore di incendio decisamente peggio
un incendio bisogna spegnere salvare le
provviste dai sappiamo
medico zaia è tornata dolore di tutto
questo abbiamo perso la radio ma è
tornata dolore attenzione tutto bruciato
la mia non mi ha sbloccato anche la ci
mette del bruciato meno una radio però
signore signori dolores è tornata quindi
una zuppa due bottiglie una torcia vabbè
oggi siamo un po spaventati perché la
mappa è caduto e dietro abbiamo scoperto
una specifica sua forte vai proviamo che
non mi ricordo cosa c'è forse gli
scarafaggi mutanti non mi ricordo il
fungo quello strano oppure no forse c'è
dell'altro per bastano una fisarmonica
non ho mai capito se quando mandi
qualcuno fuori se effettivamente serve
dargli da mangiare perché stanno
sparando nei capibile tipo a mangiare
lei affamate ha bisogno d'acqua e non
vedo un cazzo non si lavano fuori acqua
e cibo a tutti tranne a lei perché lei
va fuori quindi numero 2 dove ne frega
niente sostanziale teoricamente dovrebbe
andare tutto per il verso giusto perché
lei che va fuori non ha bisogno di avere
cibo perché tanto quando torna è come se
non ci fosse come se non come se
saltasse il bisogno di mangiare bene
teoricamente poi magari mi sbaglio io e
muore prove questa è la prova del nove
se torna viva e perché non c'è bisogno
di dargli da mangiare quando escono se
torna viva tifavano p 72 ore con mangia
visione di più tempo per riposare sembra
sfida ma che cosa c'è da cosa c'è da
fare tutto il giorno dormi è tornato a
lei j league 2 12 litri d'acqua brava
mary jane una scatoletta paradossalmente
la scatola è l'acqua è quella che va via
subito e adesso siamo a corto solo di
cibo allora vedi che vedete che non
serve dare acqua e cibo prima che esca
una persona o poi anche non dargliela
abbiamo poche provviste il morale a
terra poi c'è un piccolo gruppo di
sopravvissuti che l'altro vecchietti
dell'ospizio
no vecchietti nell'ospizio non ci andare
perché ci hanno i kalashnikov
poi la prendiamo del deretano come
sempre quindi o beppe ragazzi al giorno
19 state tutti benissimo londi voglio
sentir fiatare non vivo c'è un cane si
trova io ho sentito la bara un abbaio un
abbaglio trucca ho sentito un cane
il mondo è finito a chi importa lavarsi
ecco spiegata dalla gente che prende
l'autobus che ce ne ha contratto una
malattia da corsa chi mi chiama ma dov è
ma non fate niente al mattino alla sera
ma dove non c'è solo medikit raga non
posso curarmi tutti e 21 timi che mi
sembra più utile già tutti devono
mangiare non abbiamo cibo e tutti
beviamo scambio bottiglie d'acqua per
cento di solito il suo gioco i ragazzi è
contrario situi sto gioco ai l'acqua sei
a posto perché il cibo si consuma molto
più lento d'acqua diventarlo quale acqua
cielo a pitre invece no il cibo ma i
geni conti ma se a prendere a cioè
segnare farci capire che un giorgio il
giorno speciale per lei va bene
regaliamo nelle carte tanto stanno quale
può portare un gene nome non è che le
rotte e mica scema abbiamo ancora da
mangiare a tutti però ragazzi dovete
allora no tranne attimi che possiamo
mandarli in spedizione timi spedizione
cosa portiamo fuori sempre solite cose
l'appello avendo con la grappa ragazzi
ma non so se effettivamente serve la
mappa perché la mappa
penso che lo aiuti a orientarsi città ma
in realtà non ne ho idea
non so serata mi occupa uno slot potrei
anche non metterla in mezzo così almeno
porta più roba in casa non lo so
allora dove sarà vietato mangiare
qualcosa bisogna vedere cosa sembra
finita ma è che ci ha omaggiato sempre a
mangiare tutti i do acqua tutti
aspetto ancora un joe anzi non ho niente
aspetto ancora un giorno e poi do tutto
a tutti non sia acqua né cibo non
scappate
ok va bene
ma avere a quel cibo per tutti ok
scommetti che tim in giro trova il papa
è quella che tra l'altro è possibile che
lui torni non così in avanti nel gioco
secondo me più all'inizio però è
possibile che lui bussi alla porta che
torni era successa una volta lo ricordo
che non era entrato in tempo e poi
tornando giorno 31 o dei proietta bravo
tv mangiamo questi bravo complimenti
bravissimo bravissimo proiettili 4 ri
acqua certo ma si tanto mangiati le
bottiglie non posso dargli da mangiare
solo da bere questo è tragico e tra di
uno scivolone uscivo vietato bioetanolo
invece la porta che ha vestito che
rimandano rappresentate la famiglia non
ha armato la incontrastato al luogo
prestabilito vai
vai vai dolores bye bye bye che ci
devono dare il cibo sono siamo morti
stimolando decimo ti prego di milano 35
chimiche di non decido di nitida nel
cibo non ti ha dato dal cibo la coppia i
gemelli fratello e sorella che si sono
assunti l'incarico di esplorare e
vestiva la città ci ha detto che
sarebbero che sanno dove trovarci che ci
contatteranno sui servizi a loro una
mano ma noi serve una mano vivido
dell'acqua tutti quanti perché devono
mangiare bere bussare alla porta offrono
mi serve al cibo un fucile per questo si
italo la fisarmonica top e la mappa per
le carte va bene chiudo tutte e due
hanno non possono delle due allora dammi
il fucile così si suicidano scambio ecco
non ha da mangiare mangiati fuggire
tornando allo stato la spedizione abbia
notato le visioni su un muro era
contrassegnato una ics sai sono segrete
verifichiamo se vai dolore scorri dio
devo per forza votare perché ho bisogno
di cibo tanto mary jane non è più
tornata non solo altro è successo chi mi
è scappato come ma no ho trovato
l'insetticida che lava le faccio una
sega dolore sono più che cosa ha trovato
il fondamento non è solo quello la fama
fatti i pazienti ma niente di cantautori
qualcuno vuole darmi del [ __ ] cibo di
pregiate una radio non me ne faccio
niente della radio niente infatti mary
jane è morta
niente sono rimasto con dolores
difficilissimo raga in modalità media
difficilissimo piatto che non uscivo
dovere si dice di stare bene ma non ne
siamo sicuri dagli dell'acqua e speriamo
di farla partire speriamo che non muoia
adesso è morto è veramente un gioco
difficilissimo però spero che vi sia
piaciuto questo era sexy 6 con ci
vediamo l'anno prossimo 2022 colpo sia
episodio mi piace anche la di socialità
test iniziale certi siti iscrivetevi e
noi come sempre ci vediamo al prossimo
video della ragazzi
[Musica]